[Music]
hey folks what's going on today
it's sunday
you seem like you're feeling better
today a little bit better i mean you
slept most of the days yeah i've slept
for [ __ ] three days i mean yeah so
what time did you get up was it like two
or three or something like that more
like around uh one one o'clock oh okay i
didn't hear you until no i was like
12 30 one o'clock someone died damn
yeah you know
sleeping solid
that's good i mean you know you sound a
lot better you just seem like you
haven't been coughing as much yeah but
you know that's good i'll be up to full
speed in a couple days yeah it'll be
fine
uh so before we get i see murder hornet
is in the comments so i wanted to show
because uh he's the one that moved away
a little bit i can't watch watch watch
okay i don't want to hit my knee on that
because
you know where spock is i know but i'm
just saying i don't if i move over like
my knee will hit that and everything
will fall down all right he's the one
that sends the um
the stuff right yeah he says yeah yeah
so look at check this out yeah look at
he sent me this yesterday yeah look how
[ __ ] cool that is yeah i love i love
that kind of [ __ ] mexican lady death so
thank you very much yeah that's like
that's super cool that's super cool all
right so you want to start talking about
this movie yeah so we
the funny thing about it like i said we
usually go we have a bunch of streaming
services so we'll usually go on sort of
like amazon prime or whatever and we'll
go to the free to me section if we're
not looking for anything specific and
just see like what they have put up
there now this movie schizoid
uh we noticed it i think like last week
at some point we're like oh well maybe
that we'll keep that on the back burner
yeah we saw the trailer when i was a kid
in the theater yeah it scared me yes i
remember it
yeah so we were kind of and i was kind
of like well it's from 1980 um you know
it's kind of like a slasher type movie
and i was like oh that might be good so
we'll put that on the back burners then
last night we didn't really have
anything planned so i was like man why
don't you know we were thinking about
one but one movie but it was like i was
like ah it's kind of long and it's like
i'm kind of sleepy so let's pick
something shorter so we picked this one
now what i didn't know when we first
started watching this was one
it's uh canon films yeah and two klaus
kinski is in it yeah so i was like how
did i not know about this movie we
totally should have watched this sooner
so we ended up watching it and i kind of
feel like um
not a lot of people like really talk
about this one it doesn't even have
it has like a blu-ray release but i
think the most recent one was
maybe scream factory and it's actually
like on a double feature with this other
canon movie from the same era which is
called x-ray or hospital massacre or
something like that um so i don't even
know if it like comes out on its own
but this was actually like a pretty
solid little i you know what i wouldn't
and you pointed this out as well
and i've seen other reviews of it that
said the same thing it's called a
slasher and i guess it sort of is but
it's actually more like a giallo film
not as stylish as that
but
it's more like a very very low budget
like brian de palma like an american
giallo style murder mystery type thing
and it has like some giallo style tropes
to it yeah it feels italian
it does in a lot of ways which like i
said so i can't imagine it's weird
because i was watching it and most of it
was not familiar but then there were two
scenes in it
in particular the one scene where the
dinner scene where that and we'll get
into in a little bit where the daughter
is like half is
wearing the mom's dress and having a big
like busy fit yeah i remembered that so
i was like maybe i have seen this and it
just didn't like register all that much
like maybe i saw when i was a kid
because i remember that scene and i
remembered like one more scene like
towards the end
but
yeah so it's amazing that i haven't seen
this it is very it's not like i'm not
saying it's like some lost masterpiece
or anything like that but it's
interesting that
because this is only
what like a year or two after halloween
came out this is the same year 1980 was
i think the first the same year that the
first friday the 13th came out so you
would think that if canon
was gonna do because their whole thing
was like low budget knockoff kind of
stuff you know so you'd think that they
would just do a straight up slasher
movie like with naked teens and stuff
like that but
they seem to try to do something a
little bit different like i said it's
more giallo style because
it's not really focused on teenagers
it's more focused on you know adults and
murder mystery in it you don't know who
the killer is yeah and the killer even
has like a black like a black glove
kills people with scissors um you know
has the hat and you know they're in
shadow most of the time yeah there's a
lot of [ __ ] herrings red herrings
yeah so it's that it's like everybody
like yeah everybody's a suspect like
everybody is super sketchy and
everything like that the funny thing
about it and i think that maybe this was
why they put klaus kinski in it
they put klaus kinsey and christopher
lloyd is in this as well like and this
was way before back to the future he'd
been in taxi though right because that
was the 1970s so he played he played a
weirdo on that show too he plays a
weirdo in this um kind of like a creepy
loner type of dude
and
i think the whole thing about it is like
if we put klaus kinski and christopher
lloyd in this movie
then everybody will think that they're
the killers you know what i'm saying so
maybe that's kind of why like they put
them in there specifically
but
so the the plot of this movie it mostly
revolves around
this woman whose name is julie
and she's like what like a newspaper
columnist right like an advice columnist
or something
and she's getting a divorce from her
husband he also works at the newspaper
although i'm not entirely sure what his
job is
like he seems to have an office
but then he's like oh i'm staying at
night like to put up wallpaper i'm like
surely they have people to do that like
if he was just a reporter or something
but i don't know so i don't know what
his job is but he works there too so
they're getting a divorce she wants it
he doesn't
now she's also a member of this
kind of like therapy group i guess
which is led by klaus kinski not klaus
kinski but the character he plays who's
like a doc what's his name doctors he
always plays himself dr fails yeah uh
who's like this german you know german
doctor and he just like sits there and
listens to all their problems
and slowly like the members of this
therapy group
that the female members generally start
getting kind of like bumped off one by
one with by a killer
wielding scissors who you just see in
like shadow
so as i mentioned like everybody in this
is
a suspect like everybody well
particularly klaus kinski because he's
just like weird as [ __ ] all the time
there's kind of an unexplored
uh
subplot i don't even know if i call it a
subplot
where
him and his daughter seem to have a
weird like incestuous vibe going on yeah
which in real life he was known for that
that's what i'm saying and it's like and
i don't know if people knew about that
at the time no like in 1980 i don't
think they did but there's like this was
a bad man he was he's [ __ ] crazy well
the one woman that's in this she wasn't
like a major part the woman that played
the stripper you know what i mean um the
one woman where he's having sex with her
in her dressing room
um
she said yeah he was like doing all kind
of [ __ ] he wasn't supposed to be doing
and uh she was like really really
uncomfortable and she said he was
horrible and she hated it he's bad dude
he's like he's not a good dude so yes
he's like super creepy in this but the
thing about it is that
you almost in a way you almost kind of
like the way the plot goes you almost
kind of like feels more sorry for him
toward the end because he does actually
have a few
scenes in this where you like feel bad
for him but he's so skeevy and it's like
he's he's a doctor right he's a
psychiatrist psychologist whatever he's
the head of this therapy group and yet
it seems as though he is banging every
single woman in this group i'm like that
is very unethical sir
very unethical what's funny about the
movie is that it feels very italian but
having grown up
part of my [ __ ] early years in
california it's it's set in california
yeah
so
it's kind of foreign and familiar at the
same time when you watch it
it's a cd areas of [ __ ] la then it
goes up into the hills
with the upper middle class where a lot
of celebrities lived actually in those
days although
those houses if you were to probably go
to probably go there today they're
probably run down looking at [ __ ] but
they were worth a lot of money back in
the day it's probably worth [ __ ]
millions now
yeah everything really did look very
seedy yeah it looked that way back then
i remembered it yeah i was i was you
know i was in military school at that
time
the standards were lower back then
though
you know what i mean like i don't know
that's not sure i would've seen a house
like that it looked high-tech right yeah
but yeah i remember those do you look at
it now and it just looks like [ __ ]
two-bit cheap motels everything looked
like that
bad interiors
but they're coming back as kind of
nostalgia
i was particularly amused by one of the
first scenes because there's like a lot
of really a lot of like gratuitous
nudity in this like i said it's not usu
it's not mostly focused on teenagers
it's mostly like women in their 30s or
something but you know but they're a lot
of them do get naked so if that's what
you're into it is a little bit sleazy
not as sleazy as
you know something like uh the new york
ripper which i just rewatched again the
other day not as sleazy as that i mean
not not many movies are as sleazy as
that but it does have that kind of like
sleazy element to it there's a lot of
boobies it looks like porn's gonna
happen old porn yeah well yeah and
particularly like
honestly it's well it's not the first
scene because there's like a credit
scene where she's like working on her
typewriter or whatever but then like
literally the second scene
is her and all her female friends from
the therapy group
in the hot tub out in the backyard
they're all naked they're all sitting
there drinking margaritas or whatever
the [ __ ] and i was like you know just
like you do with your other middle age
women friends
so they're all playing they're naked
talking about she's talking about you
know
oh i'm kind of sad to be divorcing my
husband and they're like ah he sucked
don't worry about it yeah california 70s
80s they did do that
yeah
yeah they thought that [ __ ] was cool
yeah they're hot tubbing yeah hot
tubbing well [ __ ] they'd do that [ __ ]
down [ __ ] sequoia national [ __ ]
redwood forest you just [ __ ] next
thing i went down one time i was a
little kid and [ __ ] everybody was
naked
little girls [ __ ] teenagers
everything
well they and someone well like there's
normal in the movie like someone who is
it's in the movie like someone's
watching them like yeah are they like
then they're taking pictures yeah you
don't find out to who it is until later
on yeah um danny rowling says does
christopher lloyd get killed in this
film no does he i don't remember i don't
think he gets killed in this this is not
a bad movie it's actually a pretty good
movie it's pretty solid it's it's uh
it's well made solid uh it's got a
coherent story it's very workmanlike it
has a good score
uh the edit is pretty good for the time
it's it's a movie of its time
but i i actually kind of i thought the
movie was enjoyable it was solid not a
bad movie yeah like i said it's not
like i said it's not a lost classic or
anything like that but if you like they
made a lot of [ __ ] during this time and
this is one of them if you like brian de
palma's [ __ ] and you want to see
like a very very low budget version of
like a brian de palma movie so like an
american
style giallo movie is essentially what
this is with lots of boobs it's not
super gory
um there's some like stabbings and stuff
like i said it's mostly scissors but
there's nothing like
like over the top cory like a lot of the
italian films technically this is better
than uh
than the than first two friday the 13th
i like the friday the 13th 13th better
but technically this is a higher budget
movie it feels like you know even though
as far as i know according to wikipedia
it only costs 350 000. okay so to make
it just clean the way they made the
movie is pretty good yeah well the guy
that directed it david paulson
um he did a handful of movies including
another slasher back in 1976 which is
called savage weekend but he was mostly
known for going on to do
uh all your big prime time soap operas
like dallas and knott's landing and
dynasty and stuff like that so it's that
guy it kind of reminded me of that
old movie uh maniac
not as gory
well way not as gore and it's funny
because john goris said new york ripper
is my favorite fulchi that in zombie
yeah and i'm i recorded just today um a
review of new york ripper and i just
rewatched it and that's another movie
that is very very much like maniac but
it's
maniac's a lot more over top is a lot
sleazier and new york ripper is like 10
times sleazier than that
but you so you agree it's kind of like
maniac but just clean more solid more
cleaned up
but it kind of
also early stuff
oliver stone you know like [ __ ] uh
the hand you know it's kind of like that
level whatever yeah i mean it did
definitely feel like there are you know
one of the women that's in the group is
a stripper so obviously she's gonna be
naked there's the weird like incestuous
[ __ ] going on with
klaus kenzie like literally the first
time that you're introduced to klaus
kinski and his daughter like in the same
house because i guess she like he gives
he does the therapy sessions like in
their beautiful palatial estate and she
listens in on them because i guess she
just gets her jollies like that but the
first scene
he's like looking her she's getting
undressed like in the bathroom or
whatever and she left the door open on
purpose on purpose and he's like looking
in there kind of like grinning and she's
like kind of grinning i'm like she's
coming on too i was like wait is that
his daughter and then like indeed yeah
that is yeah that is his daughter it's
super weird any movie klaus kinsey's
going to be in
he's going to be the center of all
attention of all these women and
that would only happen to klaus can't
see yes my daughter she's trying to
seduce me that's how hard i am
and that's kind of duty well and like i
said he's he's literally banging every
single not only i mean i don't know if
he's banging his daughter in the movie
i'm just like saying he's like creeping
on her but he's banging pretty much
every woman that's in that therapy group
yeah like he's banging the stress i'm
like i don't i don't know klaus
i don't know where you're seeing this
you know man i'm [ __ ] i'm looking at
it
but in klaus's mind and in his in not
in his in his legend in classes [ __ ]
legend klaus is always [ __ ] all the
women are trying to bang him
i don't know how it happened and it
happened i don't know how it happened
you got to face like a damn pug dog you
know [ __ ] to me andy's crazy crazy crazy
well maybe dude just ugly you know i
don't know i don't know if i'd say ugly
he's definitely strange looking dude
[ __ ] crazy looking but he's but he
also but he looks like a crazy person
yeah you know what i mean i don't i
don't know if i'd necessarily call him
ugly but he
for sure looks like a crazy person ugly
when he was young but the [ __ ] older
he got the uglier that [ __ ]
looked ugly i mean the one scene like i
said
so he's for sure like banging the
stripper because they show that right
like she does her strip deal and then he
goes in the
uh dressing room after and they're like
banging against the wall and she's all
into it but then he starts kind of like
more seriously dating the main character
julie
um
and they remember the one scene where
they're just like standing there looking
at each other and she's like talking
about her ex-husband or whatever and he
just like
goes whoa and just like comes in for a
kiss or whatever and then tom totally
called it he said because he put his
hand on the side of her face like oh my
god he's totally going to stick his
fingers at her bow yeah and he did of
course like not really but he just kind
of like
does that kind of thing and i'm just
like ew and then like later on there's a
sex scene where they're having where
they're and i'm just like this is so
uncomfortable
it was anybody other than klaus kinski
it wouldn't be but there's just
something like not i don't know he just
seems very like creepy and predatory and
yeah and it's just how funny it's just
funny how like
he has this whole thing and and like i
said he plays
a relatively normal
person in this other than the incestuous
thing
other than him banging all of his female
patients which like i said is very
unethical
but for clap for a klaus kinski
character
he's pretty normal like he's pretty
subdued like you know he's uh
his wife died right although i don't
think they specify that and that's kind
of the issue with like the daughter and
it's like she's mad because you know you
didn't care that mom died you were too
busy working and yada yada and now
you're trying to like replace her with
this other woman and she's not having it
so there's that kind of thing and
but i don't know he's like pretty
subdued in this and even a little bit
sympathetic toward the end
but
i don't know it's still kind of like
it's still kind of like creepy but it
works like i said i think they put him
in here because everybody's like oh well
the movie's called schizoid and klaus
kinski is in it so just put two and two
together yeah but
and the thing about it is the movie's
called schizoid that wasn't the original
title the original title was actually
molded to murder which what the [ __ ]
does that mean that doesn't have
anything to do with anything that's a
jealous title or something i mean that
doesn't even that's not even good as a
giallo title it doesn't have any animals
or colors or anything or anything like
that in it
um and then it was going to murder by
mail which actually makes a little bit
more sense because one of the main plot
points is that julie
has started to receive like all of these
creepy
death threat letters that are all kind
of like cut up like ransom notes and
stuff so that's kind of like a big thing
that happens in there like the what
brings the police in and whatnot so that
makes more sense but then i think they
just change it to schizoid because
they're like oh it's like a snappy
one word title that kind of sounds like
psycho psycho but nobody is really a
schizoid in this i mean even though
the therapy group like the psychiatrist
and everything is like a big part of the
plot like none of there's nothing wrong
with any of those people there's 1980
yeah all right nobody knew what a schizo
was that's just that just means crazy
person so they just put that up there oh
yeah yeah let's go see the
that's going to see the great they were
walking around with thesaurus and
[ __ ] dictionaries and [ __ ] just oh
yeah lips gets up [ __ ] oh yeah
they're stabbing the face every time
that's all it is that's all it is well
i'm just saying i don't mean to be
pedantic or anything but like schizoid i
mean a schizoid disorder is a specific
thing and nobody they didn't know nobody
in this movie has that they didn't know
or care in nigeria i mean there is
somebody in there murdering people and
they're obviously a lunatic but it's not
the the
the symptoms they're portraying or not
yeah schizoid but like i said it's it's
a it's a snappy title it's a snappy
title so yeah other than klaus kinski
christopher lloyd is in this too like i
said he's not like super over the top
he's actually he's just kind of more of
like a lonely creeper type dude he's
actually in
the therapy group too
and he's mostly just there as a red
herring i kind of wish they'd put him a
little bit more in there because he was
like a really good character
but he's also like a maintenance man
who's working in julie's building and he
always seems to be like lurking around
because he's working on the boiler and
all this other kind of stuff
then you also have actually the woman
that plays julie
when i first saw her in the hot tub or
whatever i was like god she is a dead
ringer for bonnie bedelia from you know
uh die hard
uh it's not though it's actually
marianna hill who was actually in she
was in messiah of evil which we just saw
not too long ago she was also a high
plains drifter of many many other things
this also has playing her
ex-husband her soon-to-be ex-husband is
craig wasson
who was also in another it was in a
brian depalma movie body double he was
also in ghost story and he was a
nightmare on elm street three
now the actress that plays klaus
kinski's daughter donna wilkes
i saw her face and i was like man where
the [ __ ] have i seen her like what movie
was she and it was driving me crazy and
i said i know it's a movie that i've
seen a bunch of times because she's very
very familiar but i couldn't place her
it was [ __ ] jaws 2 she was in jaws 2.
that's where i saw her from she was also
in a movie called angel actually yeah i
actually quite liked jaws too now jaws 3
that was that was a different
that was a different kettle of sharks
and uh jaws four was straight up awful
although
michael kane was in it
and i don't think i've ever seen it i
saw it in the theater that's how much of
a sucker they tried to bring michael
kane in to save jaws for four they did
damn it was uh was he yelling
yeah i'm pretty sure he was yelling
angry it's been a while since i've seen
it yeah but the whole premise of four
was that the shark remembered the brody
family and followed them down to florida
i want to say i think it was florida
members yeah yeah shark river that's a
different that's a smart ass shark it's
like yeah you guys are
you know particularly delicious so i'm
gonna follow you around the snack on all
your relatives you should maybe see it i
haven't seen it in a long time but i
remember it being terrible but it might
be so terrible that it's like super
entertaining you know what i mean john
goris said angel was cool the one
from that's what i'm saying you love
michael caine yeah so i'm actually
surprised you've never seen it yeah so
uh donna wilkes was also an angel which
i think i saw once or twice like back in
the day but i don't remember that much
about it but i'm just like i know her
from jaws too that's how come i
recognized her so yeah so the thing
about it i don't know like i said it's
not like
it's not like terror train yeah it's
kind of like it's not this big fantastic
oh my god nobody sees this nobody talks
about it or anything like that it's just
very like you said it was very
workmanlike yeah i liked that
like i said canon who were kind of known
for doing these sort of like schlocky
over the top but i guess that was kind
of later when they went
my canon shirt
thing is done i got one uh [ __ ] tank
top done with it i don't really like the
shirt i don't know i don't that those
tank tops don't fit real well i need
just a better size
but the design came out real good i got
to do ocp next and then i'm done
oh yeah yes
because it takes a while to do the
screens yeah i got to make the screen so
because ocp will be the last one is the
um
is the developer stuff like working
because i know it's kind of old and it's
working yeah
michael caine voice is he [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
does he said is the shark [ __ ] yeah
the ultimate that would be a whole
different movie the ultimate michael
caine movie is the [ __ ] the hand you
guys haven't seen that one and the
island which is a forgotten classic
about [ __ ] michael kane
dealing with pirates pirates in the
david warner the pirate david warner's
he's a pirate and it's a good it's a
great those are both
uh [ __ ] and that one's a florida
movie
yeah that's taking place in the kitchen
well i think jaws floor jaws four is a
florida movie too that's pretty sure it
takes place you gotta see it then i mean
we'll see if it's on anywhere tonight
yeah um but
there's a couple other movies that i had
like in mind for like the matinee ones
like i said this one we just picked it
out random because i was like because
you said you remember it from the
trailer and i was like oh it's a slasher
it's from 1980 i don't think i've ever
seen it so like i said it's not don't go
into it thinking it's gonna be like
friday the 13th it's a lot more like a
bryan de palma movie than friday the
13th like i said it's not teenagers but
it's still like pretty sleazy it's still
kind of weird um
i'm not sure how
was it hard to figure out who the killer
actually was
i don't know
i really didn't care at the time i was
just watching it
we'll see but that's the kind of thing i
think about because i watch a lot of
glow movies and i'm always kind of like
we'll see usually almost always in
giallo movies or murder mysteries or
anything like that it's gonna be the
person that's the least likely so if
somebody's out there christopher
lloyding out or klaus kinskiing out
you're like well it's obviously not that
they're not gonna give you any authentic
clues
there aren't any authentic clues anyway
there'd be no way of [ __ ]
you know
taking somebody out of the out of the
running or not because the clues are all
fake
they keep showing you scissors and [ __ ]
i mean it kind of did in this case it
kind of did because this the mystery in
this one is a little more complex than
it appears
uh at you know it kind of first blush so
this one is actually like a little bit
clever in that regard but it still
adheres to the giallo formula of most
obvious crazy person
like you know skulking around and
everything like that is probably not the
killer
um so it does kind of like i don't know
if i want wouldn't like spoiler the
killer is but uh let him watch it
let him watch it but yeah if you have i
don't know if it's free anywhere else
but we watched it on amazon prime and it
was free on there and it's definitely
worth watching if you're into that kind
of thing and you have 90 minutes to kill
i mean you could certainly do a lot
worse it's a fun period piece yeah going
back in time and watching the way it was
back in the 70s and you know very early
80s it's like the it's like the movies
of the time you won't be disappointed if
you like that movies from that era yeah
it's a it's it's
kind of
it's not a good one it's not a great one
it's not a bad one it's just like one of
the one of the decent yeah it's pretty
solid yeah it's pretty solid and there's
like a lot of people in it you'll
recognize and it's always fun watching
klaus kanski being like a creep
in his movies uh murder hornet brings up
blame it on rio jesus christ i haven't
seen that in a really long time i used
to see it on cinemax like way all the
time back in the old days john gore said
michael caine was famous for signing up
for movies based on whether the
locations had nice weather during
shooting time yeah aka nice vacations
well you know i mean if i was an actor
and somebody was saying hey you want to
film this movie in like the [ __ ]
arctic or you want to film this movie in
this really nice temperate climate like
you know which one you're gonna pick
well howard stern you know he he was
when he was training to do his movie
private parts
he took the michael caine actor training
package it came with a bunch of videos
and everything and he mentioned that he
said that [ __ ] you know michael caine
says you only you know before you take
any job you want to know where it's
going to be the location whether or not
they're going to pay for your for your
hotel and whether or not you know
they're going to [ __ ] let you eat for
free at the hotel and because you know
he says don't kick out any money for
food for food and logic
you know that you you want to you know
you want free break breakfast every
morning you know from the hotel
it's a yeah of course which
michael caine just made a living [ __ ]
going on tour making these movies
[ __ ] all year round well i mean like
i said you can that's what you do you
can't blame people
it's like they're coming they're doing a
job and it's just kind of like anybody
else like if they have like a bunch of
different job prospects it's like well
which one is going to give me the most
perks yep didn't matter there's nothing
there's nothing you didn't give a [ __ ]
about underhanded about that didn't give
a [ __ ] about the script or [ __ ]
anything like that it was mostly will
you take care of me dear feel me
that's and he was constantly filming so
that's
be like a rock band going on tour that's
all you care about yeah he didn't care
if the movie made the money made he
didn't care if the movie made money or
not
i mean he was just working he got his
paycheck yeah he got food he got lodging
yeah he got to spend some time like on
nice beaches nice [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
like i said can't blame him somebody was
offering me millions of dollars to go
around and like shoot a movie somewhere
yeah like a vacation place
i don't think he cost that much i think
it was probably like in the tens to the
hundreds of thousands of dollars
uh but you had to take care of him
during the time and you had to have a
set amount of time that you'd be taken
care of
so filming was over if filming was over
early you still got to stay there for
the [ __ ] 90 days that they that he
said
yeah because it would [ __ ] up your
schedule yeah you know so i wonder how
much michael kane commanded at the
height of his
career by a couple million a year i
would imagine all i added after a couple
million a year i mean well i don't know
well i mean i'm sure he got a lot more
money than that for playing alfred in
the batman movies yeah but that was
later on yeah that's true talking about
back in the back in his heyday yeah but
it was the youngest of the 80s they
didn't make that much money
yeah that's true i mean they did compare
to the average person but
yeah i was gonna say not much money they
didn't have billion dollar movies back
then
that's right
where yeah i made this movie i could buy
three mansions on this movie you know
just they did that didn't happen
danny rowling said what does btk dennis
rader think of giallo july i'm sure he
probably doesn't think about it at all
yeah
giants can't make movies
only americans can make movies
bck seems like one of those kind of
people
no they can't speak english
they can't write scripts
nobody yeah you have them in their own
language but but that's not a real
language it's just chicken scratch
doesn't translate
doesn't translate to english well you
know
[Laughter]
who cares
[Laughter]
they can make a car but they can't
really make movies
and they can they make some pretty
kick-ass pasta dishes too how does that
don't ever buy a ferrari
constantly adjusting valves on them
like you would know yeah
he would he would know that
[Laughter]
oh my god
push rods not push rods
you don't want that desmadromic stuff
yeah
okay you're you're just really too good
at like channeling dennis rainer it's a
little bit scary yeah all right but yeah
so uh like we said this is a pretty
decent uh flick that we just kind of
came across
that i hadn't seen before and you hadn't
seen before so you know check it out if
you want to if you don't that's okay too
uh so yeah we'll be back tomorrow
talking about
another movie but i don't know which one
yet because we haven't watched it so
thanks for dropping by and hanging out
with us have a good rest of your weekend
and we will see you guys again tomorrow